made a united 28 this frightening scene
on board a united airlines passenger
flight has led to the grounding of some
boeing 777 aircraft around the globe
large pieces of the plane's pratt
whitney pw 4000
engine fell over the suburbs of denver
colorado
shortly after takeoff the plane landed
safely and no one was hurt
but u.s regulators quickly stepped in to
investigate
and on sunday the federal aviation
administration
issued an emergency directive calling
for stepped-up inspections
focusing on the engine's fan blades
united announced it would voluntarily
and temporarily remove
24 of its 777s from use
saying safety was their highest priority
it has another 28 of the planes in
storage
it's yet another setback for boeing the
u.s
aerospace manufacturers 737 max
only recently returned to flight after
being grounded for 20 months
due to two fatal crashes in less than a
year
and more trouble for united which
like other airlines has seen a drastic
reduction in travelers
due to the coronavirus pandemic
other than united airlines in the united
states
the faa says the pratt whitney engines
are only used in south korea
and japan the investigation is
continuing
kristin salumi al jazeera